i think that uh what
makes me um be a good
ceo in this business is that you know it
i just speak from my heart and so it's
something that i've been dealing with
since i was a kid basically um so i'm
building something that i really
uh understand and uh and can talk to a
customer on the same level and i think
that this is the the most important
thing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we're talking to a segy from front
egg a company that i'm a very proud to
be a small angel investor in but a very
cool company that is looking at user
management and sort of the
standardization of software and how
businesses are leveraging front egg to
increase their ability to meet standards
around the world
meet seghiro dean the ceo and co-founder
of frontex over the last 15 years segi
has held senior product and software
development positions leading
engineering and product teams and
engaged with ad hoc projects of building
customer facing software applications
transforming concepts into viable
products
previously a checkpoint now with fronted
meet segui
[Music]
first of all congratulations on on the
recent incredible announcements
i know it's been a few months since your
series b has closed um
but congratulations on the recent 40
million dollar race from some fantastic
fantastic partners like like stripe um i
am very fortunate to be a very small
part of the journey as an angel investor
but but but really with the platform
that you're building here is phenomenal
and what i love as an engineer myself as
a person who who builds products that
hopefully people love you know i
understand the problem that you're
solving user management and the fact
that you know the different standards
that the world is creating for how
companies are are
allowing users to to create this
autonomous
or or the personal autonomy of user
management software so really really a
fantastic product sigi tell me a little
bit about what front egg is and then i
want to go back into who you are and how
that will whole thing ties together
awesome thanks for asking so uh
you know thanks for the warm words i
think that uh um it's been an exciting
journey so far and definitely you know
we're growing and uh
and seeing a lot of attraction and
interest uh in our product so front deck
and in essence uh you know as a user
management platform
we're enabling sas companies to go to
market much faster with a product that
meets the standard of modern sas
applications uh most of our customers
would be b2b sas companies at different
stages so it starts with uh you know
small companies and rising and we have
unicorns and
companies that already been acquired in
fortune 100 so you know the spectrum is
quite wide
but we're aiming for uh you know for b2b
companies that
want to bring a great experience for
their users and we're helping them to
achieve that by providing product
capabilities that they can customize and
integrate within their app starting from
the most basic stuff of you know
authentication login signup experience
up to the most advanced self-service
management capabilities that they
integrate within their products so
that's uh i think it sums up a bit about
us
so take me back a little bit to
something that i that i read on the
techcrunch article that um first of all
uh you know one of the one that saw some
things i believe it was a partner at
stripe who said what blew us away about
farting was how much their customers
love the product and and then it goes on
to talking a little bit about market
expectations and and standards so talk
to me a little bit about the standard of
what
customers and companies are expecting
these days and because i think that's a
really interesting key point here is
that you're not just building a product
that
that you that that is interesting you're
actually solving a pain that is emerging
due to a new standard that sort of
people are expecting off the bat they
get you know there's a there's a gap
that you that you found here
yeah definitely so you know i've been uh
developing software and mainly focused
on uh customer facing software since i
was
uh quite uh young uh since the age of 16
and you know before it was called sas
before it was called plg or whatever
uh and um and you know we were focused
on creating just um um great experience
well when i worked in small companies
and even in a large enterprise before uh
starting front tech and i think that
what happened in the last 10 years is
that um you could see kind of a movement
from you know uh um focusing on
providing great experience for consumer
applications where you know it's not a
secret like 10 years ago we would hear
about the great experience that facebook
provides or um you know similar uh apps
but
yeah you know when i when i kind of
pitch the idea of providing great user
experience in b2b uh applications people
looked at me like five years ago what
but it doesn't matter like you need to
bring great sales people right uh and
they would uh do the rest you don't even
have to have the features right you just
you just promise them and that's it so
uh you know and i think that what
changed in the last five years that um
today
the uh the buyers of those software they
would appreciate and they expect a
certain level
uh of product experience of onboarding
experience uh they want to share their
experience with other members within
their organization and kind of you see
uh that the borders between a great
consumer experience and uh organization
experience that kind of uh you know was
almost erased and uh and today you start
as a user uh and then you know you just
you know in a second you become uh
a business that buys software right from
the moment that i invited the first
colleague into the account so uh all of
those experience became really really
important
and the thing is that for uh great
companies to be able to uh provide you
know both things both the core of their
product which you know just as it was
important 10 years ago it is still the
main things and still like invest time
effort into those platform
experiences is something that you know
is very challenging especially when
you're a young team but think of it when
you're in growth you would think wow
it's not a you know it's not a challenge
right i mean growth stage but no when
you're in growth stage you're expected
to provide those experience faster and
the core experiences um even faster so
uh so you're kind of always in this race
or what am i doing here
and um
in front egg if you think of it um you
know in essence we're actually uh
solving that uh challenge uh in that
paradox so this uh sas paradox of what
do i do do i invest in the core or do i
invest in those platform experiences
which you know in the last two years we
see that both of them are super super
important how do you find people make
that made the differentiation or
distinction between something that they
need to build in-house and develop
themselves versus leverage on a standard
that front deck provides so how you know
i guess if i look you know
many years ago
authentication and login was something
that companies would prefer to do on
their own for for a variety of reasons
and and today it's almost become a
no-brainer that nobody manages their own
user authentication how do you as sort
of the leader here how do you figure out
what things are doing sort of this shift
movement where they're turning from sort
of a proprietary technology that
companies enjoy to now a commodity or a
standard that frontec will provide to
its customers
yeah so
you know let's let's uh put it like that
nobody ever uh
came to their boss like a developer and
came to their team leaders said listen
i want to develop user management like
the next right
amazing login experience
um and i think that you know at the end
of the day it comes because of several
reasons first of all you know developers
want to um do the cool stuff
the second thing is that you know
there's a lot of responsibility here so
uh the one thing that i
mentioned earlier and that's you know
providing a great experience in that
part of the product as well usually the
company or the developer even the
product manager they would not have the
knowledge on how to provide a great
experience of inviting new users of
managing their permissions of audit logs
of managing the security policies within
your account rights subscription so
that's one thing the second thing is
that there's a lot of responsibility
here because we're always dealing with
the most sensitive assets uh of um you
know of our customers that would be
their uh
usernames their emails you know all the
information uh we are handling the audit
logs for some of our customers that
means that you know it's basically
anything that goes on within the product
so you know what taking into account
those
um
you know the sensitivity and the fact
that there's a product behind it makes
it really hard for um
for those developers or product teams to
develop it in-house and provide
a great experience for their uh
customers
incredible take me
a few years down the line vision
question in a world where front egg
delivers on its milestones grows to
where you want it to grow
what what changes how how are things
different in the world
i think that a lot of the experiences
that 10 years ago as you mentioned like
authentication where
i would just develop it in house
people understand that there's a
standard behind it now and that there's
somebody there that can do it better and
that's what my customers deserve the
best
and i think that more and more
experiences like that are becoming
standardized so uh when we think about
the developer
today they deal with
very
tough things to handle right with scale
with machine learning with a lot of
smart stuff that they need to develop
and
and they will find that a lot of those
platform capabilities could be provided
uh by
people that you know do that all day so
um so we believe that more
of those experience will be standardized
and if today we think about
low code or no code as something that
competes with developers uh i think that
a few years and it will take five ten
years down the line developers will
embrace uh those platforms uh to help
them focus on what they do best and on
the more challenging and interesting uh
problems to solve and this is where
front egg even today will lay the
foundation uh to uh to provide those
experiences but but
as we grow and as the market evolves
we'll provide more and more of those
experience up to a point where you can
basically develop the best application
out there um just in a few lines of code
and uh and from day one provide the best
experiences and that's enabling
innovation at the end of the day that's
what we do
i love it and enabling innovation i love
the sort of the butterfly effect and how
you're taking this from a very sort of
maslow pyramid type of idea you know if
you're starting if you're able to solve
sort of these fundamental building
blocks or the bottom layers that's when
you when that's when companies you know
can reach that self-actualization
uh you know a sort of bucket which which
is fantastic
but but take me back a little bit to
your own journey your own you know
entrepreneurial journey you mentioned
that you've been you know you're an
engineer at heart
how does this play into sagi's story
here yeah so
it's simple as i was saying you know i
started to develop when i was about 15
year old i fell in love with web
development because it touched the uh
the end user immediately i so sure
wasn't only about creating the the cool
apis that run fast you know it was about
creating experiences
um but i also remember that you know as
a developer almost any developer i would
suffer from what we call over
genericization syndrome right so we do
everything very generic
uh and they would ask me why do you do
that you need to you know make
everything uh stupid simple
sure but uh but you know i think that i
always wanted things to scale right i
always wanted them to be secure and
robust from the get-go uh but when you
build uh a product sometimes that's not
appreciated right you just need to focus
on what uh the customer asked for so i
think in a way this was a
kind of fulfillment for me uh fulfilling
the urge of uh uh building developer
infrastructure right so because when we
build something like that
everything has to be very robust very
scalable secure from the get-go uh so
for me uh developing the
developer infrastructure product is a
way to uh to achieve that
incredible and if you're looking at
sort of the those early days the
founding of of front egg what was it
always sort of this clear vision was it
always
this really fundamental understanding of
how the market is shifting and how
organizations are shifting
from
you know sort of from from the
infrastructure layer to innovation for
you sort of the underlying premise of
frontier was this from the get-go
so
we had a theory like uh any
entrepreneurs right uh together with the
viad but
we never claimed that we know the best
or you know so we went and asked so we
asked other entrepreneurs what was their
experience in building their products
and the interesting thing is that they
all replied with the same answer so we
always knew how to make our own core
innovation
that's where we're good at
but it was hard for us when customers
came and kind of asked for you know to
make a product out of it
uh and the productization part was a big
challenge for everybody and when we
asked why
it was because of those things that i
mentioned earlier because of this
tension between creating the core and
creating the great experience that
customers expect in a sas app so
they just answered and then we started
and we started with uh
mapping what are those challenges in
building a platform building a product
and uh and we started actually to
develop small parts of it small
components and see how the market reacts
to those components and then
focusing on the um the components
basically that got the best feedback the
best traction uh and i think that this
was kind of the the strategy some would
say that uh it's a
you know an anti-startup uh strategy but
uh but i think that that's the only way
uh when you have a very broad vision to
kind of uh you know start broad and then
focus and then from that point you can
actually extend it um and and for us it
works so uh you know i think uh
i would definitely recommend uh an
approach like that for uh for other
entrepreneurs when it's applicable
obviously
and and so i think you're you're working
today with more than
150 different um
b2b co
customers and so obviously now
i guess you don't get to write much code
these days
how was that shift from
sort of engineer programmer to
strategist leader not just an internal
leader but but an external leader as
well how how did that shift play out for
you
in my previous organization in
checkpoint i managed the team of 60 70
developers product people qa
support and um
and it was great and they asked me okay
what do you want to do next you want to
be a cto you want to be a ceo and i said
it really depends
on what's the product right so
interesting but you know
going to a cyber industry for example
i wouldn't be able to be a ceo there i
can probably uh
be a cto in such a company or a vp of
engineering and something around that
but i think that uh what
makes me
be a good
ceo in this business is that you know it
i just speak from my heart and so it's
something that i've been dealing with
since i was a kid basically um so i'm
building something that i really
uh understand and uh and can talk to a
customer on the same level and i think
that this is the the most important
thing at the end of the day i could
probably pull off um
being a cto in the other company but now
i have a viad here which is uh great and
i can never be as good as him in this
business i love and how many people are
you now at front egg
so we are more than 50 people right now
and uh growing so so not far from from
the size of team that you manage the
checkpoint so obviously you know the
trivial question to be asked is you know
what's different you were managing 60 70
people it sounded like you were managing
multidisciplinary verticals and and same
goes now how how is it different that
this is your startup and i'm sure that
many many people who manage quite a few
teams
in different companies they're asking
themselves okay i wonder how it would be
if this if i were to start a company and
be in that same position
yeah so i think that checkpoint was a
great school um and uh and it really
enables people to uh to innovate you can
just look at how many great
entrepreneurs sure came from uh this
company uh so you have a lot of freedom
to uh to create um
the difference is
uh you have
basically almost no one to uh to rely on
so at the end of the day you're calling
the shots and uh
and that's the different thing uh you
can consult with people right but at the
end of the day you need to make uh the
decisions uh that's
i think a big leap uh
obviously dealing with customers
um all the time dealing with investors
everything that uh you wouldn't
uh probably do it uh at a bigger company
or something that is not yours
so that's uh a big change and i think
that uh it's it's it's a great one for
me like
i love it away from your comfort zone
and dealing with the uh exciting stuff
so last question before i let you go
back to running a crazy company
what do you love most about what you do
the the thing you love absolutely most
the thing you wake up for
what would it be
so
i'll give you an example uh please this
weekend
uh a ceo of a great valley-based uh
company just approached me on linkedin
out of nowhere and uh
and said
congrats on the funding i love the
product that you're uh building
and uh we started to chat
and uh he said we signed up and uh
invited three more members immediately
into the account it was an engineering
guy and the product guy and you know
it's a company of i think around 40
employees and he said
it just ticked every box uh that we
needed and we already completed the
first integration and to hear that from
somebody that understands product and um
and here that we've been able even in a
few days to accelerate a process for him
and now we can innovate faster uh
through our product that's just amazing
so i think that at the end of the day
we're doing that for uh for our
customers uh we're enabling that's
awesome yeah the acceleration of
innovation for them so when you hear
that you succeed in that there's no
feeling that's better than that
phenomenal siggy thank you very very
much
best of luck with uh front egg obviously
i'm i'm
i'm i i'm biased but uh but i but i can
definitely say it's an inspiring journey
and i think that those you know those
moments where somebody who understands
what's happening understands product
understands consumers
comes and says listen we generally love
your product i think that's really what
every entrepreneur hopes and aims for so
again best of luck with fronting and
thank you very very much
thanks michael
[Music]